[Music]
Phoebe don't worry it's okay I'll always
be with you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
freeze
No
[Music]
[Music]
close your time
[Music]
tell me sir what does marry come into
you way my dad maybe sounds where were
something special the glue that held it
all together
the nation
a symbol of freedom a hope we could
bring it all back if we kept on making
deliveries and connecting people
he was sure of it Sam we want you to go
west and finish what Emily started the
people she left behind have been hard at
work setting up chiral Network terminals
but these terminals are still isolated
we need you to bring them online and for
that you'll need a cupid
this is how we'll rebuild our country
[Music]
she's fine
extinctions are hold for now I was
really Pro you on the beach
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what's the other mark for clingy woman
in a cave I see
eventhough Symphonia
I owe you an apology though was the name
you were going to give your own baby if
he debated
I should have pieced it together so I
don't know what you're talking about
you're the one I wanted to sense them
time's running out
his help she needs you you have to break
some dyes to forge others
[Music]
keep me tied everything
the world still broken same as before
present
but we're still here we're still
chugging along
[Music]
we get back together didn't you didn't
have to cut all the ties walk away the
president was right about that much
wasn't anything to walk away from it's
now like I was ever welcome there come
on
even I was welcome
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we've had five mass extinctions each
caused by an extinction entity
and now it's time for number six take
care of Lu I will didn't find a working
still mother whose two-port not say it's
done enough the decommissioning order
finally came through dead poor thing was
never truly alive not in this world at
least I had no idea and so you told me
no idea that I was alive living is no
different from being dead if you're all
alone I'm on the beach Sam our Beach the
one where I was born come and find me
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm not the only one wearing masks later
there's your boss man that woman and oh
let's not forget let alone you
did I ever tell you my real name
I wanted to it's America after Amerigo
Vespucci the men who discover it's the
continent I thought it was Columbus
except America was full of it he lied
America is a lie
for this to work
I'll have to touch you
[Music]
close your eyes now picture harmony and
heartbeat you love her right
you love her there it is
oh it's almost time for the players